bon vous êtes venus pour le casting
ben oui voilà alors on va faire une
petite impro 1 c'est pour le rôle d'un
présentateur de télévision à rus bat
bien bien bien beau de toute façon moi
je prends tout non mais je crois tous
les rôles je fais les [ __ ] les flics
et dépressif les fils de obiang et ôtez
moi moi je vais vous faire inviter alors
évidemment et vous le présentateur
forcément voilà alors à whale
excusez-moi attendait sait quel genre de
présentateur c'est à dire non mais ces
intellos sympathique divertissant lourd
hockey me suis dit c'est qu'elle jean
thierry ardisson voilà voilà
[ __ ] oui et je reçois qui guy bedos
ah bah non bah si c'est le texte ah bah
non
et pourquoi pas ah non mais attendez
mars alors que si ce n est pas
maintenant ils se détestent
non mais attendez dites-moi de n'importe
qui mais guy bedos et thierry ardisson
maintenant on m'avait dit ça mais alors
est futile c'est là oui enfin c'est un
jeu et puis c'est le texte mon vieux
faut le jouer
oui mais non lola les étendant la joie
parce que si ces genres film fellinien
surréaliste complètement varie glénat
aider fiat ont cure et non moi je suis
plutôt studieux ouvriers alors guy bedos
et derrière dix ans mais pas quand et où
je rentre dans la peau du personnage je
ne sais pas moi concentrez-vous s'arrête
là alors non mais
changer juste le scénario n'a trouvé
quelque chose de plus crédible non non
non non on va se rappeler voulait pas
faire l'aumône à burnout évidemment non
non non non attendez
alors je vous fais bull fait je vous le
fais allez-y on va tous les bouts droits
devant à droite
vas-y bonsoir guy bedos
bonsoir bas qu'est ce que tu fous là
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu